TJ good morning congratulations on last
night when did you find out you were
going to start dan first off thanks for
having and secondly I heard you're up
for a sports at me so congratulations to
you
secondly during scoot around we walked
in the building I'll be around to 2 p.m.
and our assistant coach notified me that
I'd be starting in that 30 seconds later
Brad came over and told me as well big
speech no it was just like your start
and go out there and do your job what
was it like when you heard that standing
ovation and the chants of TJ in the
fourth quarter it was great
I can't say enough good things about our
fans they're truly incredible people and
fans and it was a cool moment but just
glad we could play well and get a win
inside of them what is your role in
starting as opposed to coming off the
bench what was your role or goal last
night for me I think it was just about
bringing energy and providing a spark
for our team we've got two superstars on
our team that can pretty much get
buckets whenever they whenever they want
so for me it was just about kind of
getting them the ball and doing whatever
the t means that it'll win when you are
looking at your right hand after you
score can you explain what what that is
TJ that was what I like to call an
out-of-body experience
okay wait you acted surprised that
you're scoring so you're looking at your
hand like your hand is hot no I was just
surprised how open I was and the first
thing I could think of is just look at
my hand like an idiot I don't know why I
did it
well now you got to continue to do it if
the opportunity presents itself I
definitely will how goofy is in bead on
a daily basis
it depends on what type of booties in
you know he's he's honestly one of the
most genuine nice people I know and well
you know when he's in that group in Lou
he's one of the funniest dudes I've been
around but when he's not it's all
business and steer clear from him
because he it's all about basketball at
that point and it felt like that last
night it felt like there was a little
more from him I don't know edgewise you
know him and Morris going back at each
other
Rozier and embiid and just felt like he
was we're not gonna be and we may not
win this series but you're not when
you're not went in here in Philadelphia
right Georgia always has that edge and
you know when he take it to the next
level of talking trash I feel like it it
provides a lot of energy for us and we
love when he does it
he's TJ McConnell the 76ers guard is
they lived to see another game hopefully
more than that but they got game 5
coming up in Boston by the way I want
you to count the white guy cliches here
with Ben Simmons describing your game TJ
we played this earlier it's a new game
called the count the white guy cliches
here's Ben Simmons on TJ McConnell
lesson I think it's just something not
everybody has that bet fire within him
you know he's not the biggest guy not
the most athletic but he has energy
brings every night and you know he's a
huge part of his team and I think
tonight it was a night where he really
stepped up and gave the energy so I got
six white guy cliches in 13 14 seconds
they're pretty good performance there by
Ben TJ what do you think that answer was
second to none when it comes to white
guy cliches I feel like the white guy
cliche I hear the most is he's not the
biggest or the most athletic well you
are the son of a coach right absolutely
yeah so you're probably a gym rat high
basketball IQ deceptively quick anything
else how else have you been described
do you have a favor white you have moxie
what's your favorite white guy cliche it
is like I said not that not the biggest
of the most I'm like that's what I've
heard the most honestly when did you
become the best player basketball player
in your own family um let me think I
would have to say I might not still not
be the best player in our family my aunt
is I mean she has a gold medal for
crying out loud so it's hard to beat
that
yeah Suzie was great at Penn State I
misspoke thought I said your sister but
she's your aunt but but Suzie McConnell
was at Penn State and won Olympic gold
she played in the WNBA did you play did
you ever play her one-on-one if I did it
was a long time ago when out when I was
little and my cousin her son Peter what
would play and you never see obviously
wasn't taking it seriously but you know
we'll never know now
did you are you a Pittsburgh fans sports
fan yes I am absolutely know your
Penguins went down last night too
you know I can't complain it they gave
us two Stanley Cups in a row so that was
an incredible run and it's just hard to
lose to the Capitals you know we're not
there's no love lost there but also so
Steeler fan as well yeah absolutely yeah
yeah well have you met Ben have you met
the Steelers I met Rob this burger a
while ago when I was little but it
wasn't too good of an interaction you
know I respect him as a player but he
wasn't exactly the nicest style but I
mean you know he was being bombarded by
people so I understand did you ask for
an autograph
yeah I wasn't like sixth grade we were
at a and like a hoops for a Cure thing
at my high school and you know he was
getting bombarded left and right so I
mean I completely understand it was them
coming out there for his first Super
Bowl did you cry no but to be honest I
stopped rooting for the Steelers a
little bit wait did you become an Eagles
fan no no I didn't I was I was a little
petty and rudest her some teams in our
division and then I've repaired it back
to Steeler fan wait did you root for the
Ravens no I was a Cincinnati Bengals fan
for a little bit oh well that's okay
they're not any good so that maybe you
should offer Bend tickets you know after
you beat Boston in Boston then you come
back just reach out to Ben and say hey
let's just let's kind of make this
relationship a solid one I'd like to
invite you here and all spend time I'll
have some time for you after the game
I'll see what I could do he probably
won't be too interested by the way did
Reddick help you with your haircut or
did you help Rhett like you know let
give me the genesis of that the haircut
there I feel like you know he kind of
started the what is it that Adam Levine
look and well wait didn't Adam Levine
start the animal Avene look yeah I mean
I guess he didn't know no JJ JJ copied
him and I guess people can say I copied
the AJ so I guess that's where we'll
have to go it all right good luck with
the hand the the hot hand
Game five I do not know oh my god you
know what I would do i do just four home
games though TJ because you know then
when you're winning you can do it but I
thought it was I thought it was
something you know somehow you've been
doing this a long time I thought it was
great and I'm like damn he's
his hand is so hot he's looking at it
like I can't believe I'm doing it with
this right hand so I didn't do it yeah
oh hey safe travels Congrats and good
luck in Game five thank you so much and
congrats again B you guys Thank You TJ
TJ McConnell
heard about Sports Emmy spawn a small
little world here for more Dan Patrick
show to the audience channel 239 on
Direct TV or download the Dan Patrick
show app
[Music]